[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 18 juin le dos et
le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv à 78 tout de
suite les titres de se situer du journal
le début du baccalauréat plus de quinze
mille candidats yvelinois ont planché ce
matin sur l'épreuve de philosophie nous
étions à montigny le bretonneux est dans
cette édition interview également à la
bibliothèque universitaire de guyancourt
qui ouvre ses portes aux lycéens pour
les révisions en ce jour de
commémoration de l'appel du 18 juin nous
vous proposons un témoignage déportés
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
francine christophe va à la rencontre
aujourd'hui des jeunes générations
elle s'est rendue notamment au collège
champollion de voisins-le-bretonneux et
puis en cette période de coupe du monde
nous parlerons de football mais sous
l'angle de la pratique féminine
à un an du mondial en france où en
est-on dans le département exemple au
travers d'une équipe le plaisir sporting
club son président georges gomis est
notre invité l'expérience peut-elle être
trompeuses peut-on être insensible à
l'art le désir est il la marque de notre
imperfection voici quelques-uns des
sujets sur lesquels ont dû a planché
pendant quatre heures les candidats au
bac ils sont quinze mille à 417 dans les
yvelines
315 ce matin à montigny le bretonneux à
se mesurer à la traditionnelle épreuve
de philosophie le récit avec patrick
jacques de dixmude et nicolas
kirillovitch ce sont de vieilles
habitudes répéter tous les ans à
seulement 15 minutes du début de
l'épreuve de philosophie il est temps de
vérifier et distribuer les copies selon
les filières
les surveillants et enseignants sont
dispatchés dans les classes de leur côté
les élèves s'installent à 8 heures
précises les épreuves écrites du
baccalauréat 2010 8 commence le lycée
tout entier passe alors en mode examen
je passais de salle en salle pour voir
si tout se passe bien faire voir les
professeurs s'il n'y a pas de problème
essayer de rassurer tout le monde
puisque c'est aussi une épreuve même
pour les professeurs sont les leurs
élèves qui vont passer le baccalauréat
donc voilà ils sont aussi un peu
stressée je pense à général ou
technologique plus de 300 candidats ont
passé leur première épreuve à montigny
le bretonneux
après plus de trois heures de
concentration et d'efforts les premières
réactions ont été plutôt contrastée
s'est pas franchement je sais pas philo
c'est vraiment une matière où on peut
dire oui à pro finalement est donc là
versement donc je sais pas je me suis
débrouillé je pense assez bien je pense
j'ai réussi et et on attend de voir la
suite
le deuxième sujet c'était sur la justice
et j'étais pas du tout voilà sur moi je
voulais la vérité ou le désir est là
juste la chance de tomber sur le désir
que j'étais très contente
c'était pas trop difficile mais après je
pense pas avoir réussi tant que ça
réussit ou loupé les bacheliers n'ont
plus le temps de méditer sur la
philosophie demain matin place à
l'histoire géographie si baccalauréat a
débuté les révisions elles ne sont pas
pour autant terminé avec de nouvelles
épreuves au programme des deux mains
cette année encore les lycéens ont la
possibilité de potasse et leurs cours à
la bibliothèque universitaire de l'ue vs
q le site de guyancourt a lancé son
dispositif bacs depuis début juin
entretien enregistré vendredi ori lire
11 pour les images
chantal merle bonjour un jour vous êtes
la responsable de la bibliothèque
universitaire de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines à guyancourt depuis le lundi 4
juin vous accueillez les lycéens dans
leurs révisions pour le bac le
dispositif s'appelle révisé à la baisse
but bien sûr pour bibliothèques
universitaires
on se dit des lycéens dans une baie eu
ce n'est pas forcément commun pourquoi
les accueillir nous les accueillons
parce que ce sont des potentiels
étudiants à la fin de leurs études
secondaires et que la bibliothèque a
pour mission d'accueillir tout public
non ces espaces pour se documenter
s'informer et participer à la réussite
de ses études on ne sait pas forcément
les lycéens peuvent venir ici toute
l'année
oui la bibliothèque n'est pas sous
contrôle d'accès donc tous lycéens tout
étudiant et tous habitants de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines peut venir
bien sûr le public principal ce sont les
étudiants qui sont eux sont obligatoires
mois inscrits à la bibliothèque les
autres publics doivent s'inscrire à la
bibliothèque s'ils veulent profiter de
tous les services de la bibliothèque en
lice en sont actuellement en train de
réviser derrière nous
ils sont nombreux
depuis le début du mois de juin vous
fait cette opération depuis le lundi 4
juillet ce qu'ils sont nombreux à venir
ici ce oui cette opération remporte un
franc succès puisqu'au depuis lundi donc
ça fait à peu près dix jours
nous avons enregistré est inscrit et
accueilli plus de mille cent soixante
treize lycéens de tous les siens de tous
les lycées des environs
vandier sais c'est pas la première année
c'est pas la première année la
bibliothèque est ouverte depuis 2004 et
ça fait à peu près cinq ans qu'on a mis
en place ce dispositif puisque les
lycéens viennent de façon naturelle
révisé puisqu'ils cherchent des endroits
pour travailler mais c'est surtout on a
aussi nos propres étudiants qui sont
quelquefois un peu embêté gêné par les
lycéens
il faut arriver à faire cohabiter tous
ces publics différents avec des
objectifs différents
j'allais vous relancez le dessus pas de
gros problèmes de cohabitation il ya
quand même quelques soucis c'est ce que
ce que vous dites ça les étudiants se
sentent vraiment chez eux et quelquefois
quand les lycéens arrivent et qui font
un peu joué parce qu'ils viennent de
réviser en groupe
il faut trouver des moyens pour arriver
à faire cohabiter ces publics et c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis en place ce
dispositif pour accueillir les lycéens
les acculturés à ces espaces est aussi
garder des espaces à peu aux réserves et
pour les étudiants vous en parlait il ya
des avantages bien sûr à venir révisé
ici pour le bac c'est d'abord un cadre
on imagine trouver de la tranquillité un
espace de travail idéales alors c'est
aussi pour changer d'endroit sortir de
son lit c'est grandir un peu s'émanciper
et commencer à découvrir un peu la vie
d'adulte et d'étudiants l'intérêt c'est
qu'ici la bibliothèque
à de grands espaces on a plus de 1100
places assises et les lycéens se sentent
très libre convenir c'est pour ça qu'on
est en place le dispositif et qu'on
l'aimait plus tôt au rez-de-chaussée
pour garder les espaces des étages plus
tranquille pour les études c'est son nez
dans l'auditorium c'est là qu'ils
peuvent réviser
on n'est pas dans l'éditorial on est au
niveau du raid du rez-de-chaussée et
l'auditorium c'est aussi un espace qu on
a aménagé pour que les lycéens puissent
travailler un peu plus tranquillement
puisque vous voyez bien que cet espace
résonne beaucoup et qu'on a aussi des
soucis d'acoustique et d'aménagement
d'un espace on nous livre comme ça donc
à nous d'arriver à trouver des
des arrangements pour que tout le monde
puisse travailler le mieux possible et
se concentrer pour la réussite de ces
examens
on est dans un lieu qui s'adresse bien
sûr en premier lieu à des étudiants est
ce que d'aider les lycéens peuvent
trouver tout de même des ressources des
documents peut être utile dans leurs
révisions
on n'a pas de collections spécialisées
pour les lycéens
ils peuvent éventuellement trouver des
ressources par rapport surtout au bac
français ou à la philosophie puisque on
a une collection littérature et
philosophie
mais notre principal documentation est
vraiment pour les étudiants alors pour
les lycéens qui viennent ici n'ont pas
forcément les us et coutumes d'une bévue
quand on vient dans cet environnement il
ya forcément des règles à respecter que
faut-il faire
ne faut-il pas faire quand on vient ici
dans une bibliothèque universitaire
alors en principe dans le règlement
intérieur on précise bien les usages
d'une bibliothèque bien sûr de pas trop
parler fort et de ne pas manger ni boire
on voit bien et de travailler le plus en
silence possible dans cette bibliothèque
on a
mis en place un zonage des espaces pour
des zones de travail en groupe des zones
de travail en silence et des zones de
travail en chuchotant parce qu'on se
rend compte que les usages de travail
évolue beaucoup et que maintenant tout
étudiant ou lycéen ne fait plus que
travailler en silence ils travaillent en
groupe ils travaillent en mangeant il
travaille en regardant sa page facebook
et quelquefois même y dorment dans la
bibliothèque donc il faut arriver à
concilier sous ses usages et donc bien
sûr au moins respecter a minima le
silence la nourriture et les boissons
mais c'est pas toujours évident toute
dernière chose question très pratique si
on veut venir révisé ici là l'abbaye
accueillera les lycéens jusqu'au tout
début des épreuves
comment fait-on il faut s'inscrire à
l'épée à la main l'entrée on a quelqu'un
qui accueille chaque lycée et sur
présentation de son livre est de
de scolarité ou sa carte de lycée il est
automatiquement inscrits et bien
accueillis à la bûche
merci chantal merde je rappelle que vous
êtes la responsable de la bibliothèque
universitaire de l'ue vs cul et on
souhaite bon courage aux lycéens qui
passent le bac es avec la grève des
cheminots ce lundi à la sncf pas facile
pour les candidats de se rendre sur leur
centre d'examen afin d'éviter les
mauvaises surprises la sncf active un
dispositif spécial pendant toute la
durée du baccalauréat est d'être un
stratégie garantit le matin d
information renforcée la veille au soir
des examens avec quelques bus de
substitution et 3000 personnes dans 200
gares de france pour orienter les
lycéens en cas de grandes perturbations
les rectorats et centres d'examens
seront avertis directement par la sncf
un discours emblématique a prononcé le
18 juin 1940 sur les ondes de les ondes
de la bbc l'appel du général de gaulle
inciter les français à poursuivre le
combat face à l'allemagne nazie qui
allait occuper le territoire national
aujourd'hui la ville de bois d'arcy à
commémorer le soixante dix huitième
anniversaire de cet événement une
cérémonie devant l'hôtel de ville en
présence d'habitants et d'associations
d'anciens combattants
un devoir de mémoire nécessaire pour le
maire interrogé par patrick jacques de
dixmude commémorer l'appel du général de
gaulle chaque année et d'une terrible
modernité d'abord parce que ce discours
est magnifique c'est un appel au sursaut
c'est un appel à la résistance c'est un
appel à l'honneur de la france et je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
de ces appels l'un de ces appels à ce
qu'est la france
la france de toujours la france notre
histoire notre héritage et ce discours
est aussi un exemple et un exemple à
suivre
elle a été déportée enfant dans un camp
de concentration pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale francine christophe
offre aujourd'hui son témoignage aux
jeunes générations l'illinois était
mardi dernier au collège champollion de
voisins-le-bretonneux à la rencontre des
classes de 3e un moment des changes et
d'émotions suivi par camille lambert
attention certaines images peuvent
heurter la sensibilité des plus jeunes
cette étoile c'est celle que francine
christophe portait quand elle avait 8
ans pour aller à l'école
en 1944 elle est déportée avec sa mère
dans le camp de concentration de
bergen-belsen en allemagne libéré en
1945 par les troupes russes
elle raconte aujourd'hui son histoire et
sensibilise les plus jeunes doit le
faire parce que parce qu'il faut pas
oublier et parce que comme je leur
expliquerai parvenir il faut les mettre
en garde
pour ça que même temps jamais j'apporte
des photos dans les écoles que comment
croire ces jeunes y avait des morts
partout même ça veut dire quoi
d'événements partout et non pas si je
vais revendre les photos il ya des morts
partout des images parfois difficiles à
regarder mais indispensable les élèves
de 3e du collège champollion ont pu
poser toutes leurs questions sans tabou
moi c'était surtout les conditions du
camp l'histoire qui se passait là bas
comment est-ce que ça va se passer
puis le thé tyde quand on entend le nom
de victimes
qu'elle évoque ce qu'elle a vécu mais
non tu vois ça en fait dans nos manuels
en images comme on réalise pas leur
potentiel qui parle de vivant réalise
dans ses impressions dont on avait
l'idée avec les collègues d'histoire géo
et de france est de faire un travail sur
le devoir de mémoire sur la transmission
des souvenirs ça permet de voir que
c'est pas juste des photos figé c'est
pas juste
ce qu'un professeur raconte parce qu'il
est payé pour ça mais bel et bien
quelque chose qui a existé un échange
riche avec un message
mon message c'est de leur dire que en
dépit de tout la vie est belle 12,9 12,9
millions de téléspectateurs samedi pour
le premier match des bleus face à
l'australie le score 2 buts à 1 une
entrée dans la coupe du monde suivie
également est depuis à saint quentin en
yvelines plusieurs supporters ont
regardé la rencontre entre amis dans un
bar du territoire retour avec nicolas
landry et tout kinnear il entoure
[Applaudissements]
le but salvateur après l' angoisse dans
ce bar influence pour le match france
australie
outre les yvelinois certains supporters
viennent d'ailleurs à l'image d'ambroise
venue de pontoise que c'est un pote ce
qui m'a amené ici et je connais ce bar
il est très bien moi cris acclamation
les clients sont tendues un penalty pour
la france les mines sont rassurés une
joie de courte durée la main de titi
mène un penalty pour l'australie égalité
avec la france le doute s'installe un
moment propice pour reprendre des forces
à la 80e minute peut être la délivrance
second but pour les bleus seize minutes
de la fin moments de tension sur le
terrain comme au bar au coup de sifflet
final quelques applaudissements pour un
match poussif
c'est l'inquiétude sur les capacités de
la bande à deschamps à s'était pas très
bien pourquoi n'était pas très bon mais
bon on a kiffé quand même le but la
france a gagné sur un derain et c'est un
bon début je pense que ça va être bon
pour leur moral pour la suite
ils étaient moins performants que les
deux premiers matches des peuples de
préparation ça ressemblait plus sot
match avec les us en attendant doute ou
non la diffusion de matchs des bleus
reste une aubaine pour les restaurateurs
c'était prévu qu'on n'ouvre pas à la
base parce que
voilà il ya d'autres d'autres
établissements dans les environs et que
ben voilà nous à base au samedi midi on
est fermé et on s'était dit qu'au
dernier moment avec certains retours
qu'on avait eu que des clans voulait
qu'on nous donc on a ouvert pour eux et
pour la france on va dire donc sa très
bonne surprise en plus victoire de la
france donc que du bonheur prochain
rendez vous pour les supporters le 21
juin
la france affrontera le pérou
on continue de parler football justement
avec georges gomis bonsoir vous êtes le
président du plaisir sporting club est
un club de 100% féminin du département
alors avant d'en parler à débris font
sentent déjà ce week end de coupe du
monde le match de l'équipe de france 2
buts à 1 face à l'australie la victoire
est là georges mêla manière non qu'avez
vous pensé de ce match là des jeux on
est très content d'avoir les trois
points légère par rapport au contenu du
match à un contenu du match était basse
et un match poussif au loyer
les gars ont eu du mal à rentrer dans la
partie mais avoir les trois points c'est
une bonne chose mais comme je l'aï dit
lors d'une émission en jouant un petit
peu mieux on aura peut-être beaucoup
plus de chance d'avancer dans un dans un
comment on aura plus de repères pour la
suite
mais là c'était aussi des joueurs des
jeunes joueurs cette équipe il a été
aligné ce trio-là pas été aligné très
souvent on à grease manouba pelaez d'un
bébé voilà ils ont pas été souvent
indignes et donc les automatismes d'en
brosser des jeunes joueurs ils ont
peut-être été inhibées par la pression
et puis après bon bain quand vous avez
un garçon comme giroux devant vous on
peut appeler ça un pivot on peut appeler
ça une pointe ton peuple etc ce qu'on
veut mais c'est quand même un certain
quelqu'un qui est là qui vous vous dis
qui vous permet de garder des ballons
qui vous permet de de commandes d'avancé
donc la manière peut venir encore
l'essentiel c'était pour ce premier
match de réussir son entrée en voilà
l'entrée en ondes à vue on a vu les
professionnels de la coupe du monde une
équipe comme l'allemagne où ils se
cherchent se faire battre par des
généraux mexicain les favoris qui ont
surpris et ont fait une drôle et sans
marty donc cocorico vie va vivre le
premier match et vive les trois points
du coup pas d'inquiétude pour la suite
de la compétition
on pensait que la manière peut arriver
il faut il faut trouver une identité de
jeu mais
mais vous n'êtes pas inquiet pour la
suite de la compétition on a un
sélectionneur kellock et qui a de
l'expérience qui est qui et comment il
ya un vécu qui connaît les gars qui a dû
aussi s'apercevoir des problèmes que
l'équipe de france rencontre parce
qu'aujourd'hui on pense est vrai que
l'équipe de france on n'a pas une réelle
identité de jeu on a des très bons
joueurs on va l'aider on a des commandes
des bons milieux de terrain on a des
bons attaquants
on a des défenseurs centraux qui sont
comment qui sont espérés qui jouent dans
les plus gros clubs barcelone et varane
joie à madrid et une petite y avoir à
barcelone ribéry faire des erreurs de
débutants c'est il a le ballon en fin de
compte il a perdu le ballon de vue par
rapport au centre par rapport au centre
et à la trajectoire
lui qui est gaucher et il devait être
mal positionné donc du coup n'ayant pas
vu le ballon
il savait aussi que le ballon était
était sur cette trajectoire parle bien
sûr de samuel umtiti mal acquis et
viseront le coupable d'une faute dans la
surface que c'est son placement un
moment elle a dû perdre le ballon de vue
et leurs réflexes qu'il a eu assez de
mettre la main parce qu'il sentait qu'il
y avait un adversaire derrière alors une
france décevante vous l'avait dit et
également des favoris qui ont du mal à
rentrer dans cette compétition
l'argentine qui a buté face à l'islande
le brésil qui hier a fait match nul face
à la suisse le champion du monde entier
de l'allemagne qui a perdu contre le
mexique
est-ce que d'après vous les favoris de
ce mondial sont en péril
finalement c'est qu'une entrée en
matière faut attendre les prochains
matches ils sont pas en péril mais
maintenant le niveau se resserre il ya
plus de petites équipes et on trouve des
très bons joueurs j'ai souvent des très
bons joueurs dans dans tous les
continents et dans tous les pays
maintenant les comme jeudi les ceux qui
vont vouloir gérer gérer l'italie va
vous libérer
les prévenus à la coupe du raid a donc
maintenant c'est fini maintenant le
football veut que à et puis tant mieux
pour les spectateurs il faut il faut
quand même mon démontrer quelque chose
de l'élan du plaisir de commandes de la
qualité technique des des actions
des jolies actions de du mouvement alors
maintenant si on vient pour gagner d'une
manière dans la gestion type brésil on a
vu pire
alors je rappelle que vous êtes georges
gomis le président du plaisir sporting
club c'est un club 100 % féminin alors
c'est l'occasion de faire un petit point
avec vous sur le développement du
football dans le département un exemple
déjà au travers de votre club ça fait
deux ans qu'il a été créée quel bilan
vous vous tirez ce que le club est dans
une progression et ce qui l'a attiré des
joueuses au niveau des licenciés cette
année on a quand même enregistré 52
licence dont on a pu faire une équipe
u13 qu'on va encore améliorer
l'année prochaine les premières équipes
aujourd'hui on a trois équipes mais bon
après aujourd'hui il va falloir
peut-être réfléchir à la manière de la
manière d'orienter notre politique
sportive parce que
aujourd'hui nova sur plaisir et on est
on est commandé deux clubs déjà en aide
au club plus loufoques qui a pas de
frein qui a pas de féminines un
troisième club mois et discussions voilà
moi aujourd'hui je suis dans une
on a un club quand même nous convivial
où les enfants ont eu accès à pas mal de
choses et je voudrais qu'on a quand même
avec une licence pas chers ministres 150
150 euros ils ont eu deux ballons de
foot ils ont eu pas mal de choses des
sorties au cinéma
pas mal d'activités autour moi le sport
je le conçois aussi avec du plaisir une
dernière question très rapidement chez
nos confrères de la gazette en yvelines
le président du district du football
indiqué qu'il y avait environ 20% de
licenciées féminines en plus chaque
année dans le département
vous dites vous ressentez cette
progression au sein de votre club est ce
que des des événements tels que la coupe
du monde féminine qui sera dans un an en
france est-ce que forcément le l'attend
avec impatience qu'on tournait à la tête
d'un club féminin est ce que ça peut
être positif
baj la plonge là on l'attend moi je
l'attends surtout pour l'ensemble des
ddd fille aux défis du du franc de gyan
fin de la france quoi est ce que le
football français
enfin football féminin féminin français
est très bon mais on gagne la ligue des
champions pas mal de fois donc là
aujourd'hui je pense que il faut arrêter
de dire que on va on va on va on va
maintenant il faut faire les choses pour
les filles aujourd'hui il faut se
développer le football féminin donner
les moyens aux filles les encadrer les
aider aussi à progresser
moi je comprends pas aujourd'hui en
seniors krach financier
je ne comprends pas en seniors
aujourd'hui bas il ya des clubs qui
jouent en en bad en basse divisions et
les joues les joueurs ont des z
alors que les filles elles ont jamais
rien son récent là ils sont livrée à
elle-même payé leur essence
il faut les aider parce que c'est son
sont vraiment méritante que toutes les
filles qui jouent au football sont
méritants comme tous les garçons mais là
aujourd'hui eux dans leur pratique ils
sont qu'au début des choses et là il
faut leur faut les aider à aller vais
aller vers l'avant à suivre donc merci
georges gomis d'avoir est avec nous
président du plaisir sporting club et on
peut retrouver l'actualité de votre club
sur son site internet
à qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran est du
football encore le stade guy boniface à
elancourt a accueilli vendredi dernier
des rencontres départementales c'était
dans le cadre du dispositif foot à
l'école durant toute l'année scolaire
300 élèves yvelinois du ce1 au cm2 ont
pu être découvrir l'activité un projet
pédagogique qui a mis également l'accent
sur le rôle de supporters patrick
jacques de dixmude et aurélie 11
après une année de découverte de
l'activité football ces élèves issus
d'une quarantaine d'écoles du
département s'affrontent sur ce terrain
du stade guy boniface à elancourt
même si chaque équipe portent les
couleurs d'un pays il n'y a pas d'enjeu
dans ces matches seulement des moments
de plaisir et de convivialité
duceppe la fédération française de
football et l'éducation nationale qui
sont concertés pour établir un contenu
kate qui est disponible pour les
enseignants sur un site internet dédié
qui s'appelle foot à l'école point
fff.fr qui leur permet d'avoir tout le
contenu pédagogique pour mettre en place
les différentes séances d'un site qui
fait cette séance pour faire découvrir
la pratique aux enfants sous forme de
jeux et d'ateliers techniques
cette année près de 300 élèves du ce1 au
cm2 ont participé à ce dispositif dont
l'objectif est avant tout pédagogique
montrer que le football
aussi à des valeurs qui sont éducatives
et que et qu'on peut avoir tout un
travail sur le fair play notamment par
rapport au football
les actions qui sont autour de ça tous
les matches étaient arbitrés par des
élèves issus des sections sportives des
collèges du territoire
il y en a quelques-uns des fois ils se
rebellent met chavassieux là comme ils
sont plus petits les harpies attention
aux petites fautes pour pas qu'ils se
blessent
cette année le dispositif foot à l'école
comprenait aussi un volet culturel ayant
pour thème tous supporters de l'équipe
de france pour la coupe du monde
allez la france nj - 102 avant la ryder
cup à saint quentin en yvelines les
habitants ont pu s'entraîner pendant
tout le week-end à la golf expérience
était ce samedi donc à montigny le
bretonneux le rendez vous est proposée
au grand public de découvrir la
discipline et d'approcher le trophée de
la compétition reportages et de michael
et demi d'euros et nicolas landry alors
vous avez vu vous avez arrêté votre club
vous l'avez arrêté après la frappe non
laissez le partir jouer le geste n'est
pas encore parfait jacob solari venus
découvrir ce samedi 16 juin les bases du
golfe à montigny le bretonneux pendant
la golf expérience une première pour
cette imminente 1 c'est plus simple
quand on regarde à la télé et on se dit
c'est plutôt facile
en fait c'est assez technique d'une part
c'est la position c'est le fait donc de
viser juste pas taper trop fort comme
jacob s'ils sont plusieurs milliers à
être venus découvrir le monde de la
petite balle blanche sur le quai
françois truffaut petit mme
surdimensionné practice sur l'eau tous
ont pu s'essayer au golf de façon
ludique
là c'était bien ça a l'air de bien lui
plaire après peut-être que ça va faire
appel
en parallèle l'événement organisé par
saint quentin en yvelines avait
également pour objectif de faire
découvrir la ryder cup au grand public
l'épreuve sera organisé du 28 au 30
septembre golf national et devrait être
suivi par plus de 750 millions de
téléspectateurs alors les gens
évidemment sont de plus en plus au
courant qu'ils à la ryder cup dans 100
jours donc on est très fier ça veut dire
qu'il ne notre travail de
sensibilisation à fonctionner mais y en
a encore qui découvre et qui découvre à
même le golfe après la golf expérience
le quai françois truffaut de montigny le
bretonneux se transformera fin septembre
une gigantesque fan zone pour la ryder
cup
les matchs seront diffusés gratuitement
pendant l'épreuve on referme ce journal
sur ces images samedi la verrière
organisait la fête de juin sur la
pelouse du scarabée une après midi
d'animations avec les associations de la
ville manège initiation boxe belle foot
et nombreux spectacles la journée s'est
terminée par un concert-bal les
objectifs des festivités au micro de
nicolas landry les vivre ensemble le
passé un bon moment
rassembler tous les quartiers parce que
c'est une défaite qui effectivement eu
permet aux trois quartiers de se
rassembler de se mélanger dans la bonne
humeur
quand vous voyez c'est tranquille c'est
bon enfant c'est familial aucune idée
c'est de passer un bon moment ensemble
quelle que soit
endroits de la ville où on habite c'est
la fin de ce journal dans quelques
minutes retrouver le 7-8 sport présentée
par michael ennemi doro très bonne
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]